up there is the bridge of the captain
kleban akov the Russian icebreaker
that's taking me and the rest of Chris
Hadfield expedition around the Arctic
nowadays navigation up there and well on
most ships is mostly automatic it's
handled by GPS and by computer driven
charts but hidden away up on the bridge
is an emergency backup that's roughly
the same as explorers have been using
for centuries
it's a sextant and it's used for
celestial navigation you get the angle
between the horizon and a known star
even the Sun at least when it's not
cloudy consult a lookup table and do a
bit of maths and you have your latitude
now a hundred years ago when sextant was
the only way to navigate the claims of
explorers had to mostly be taken on the
records they kept or else just on faith
to this day no one is entirely sure who
it was who first made it to the North
Pole Frederick cook claimed to have
reached it in 1908 but his records don't
really add up and while his evidence was
questioned particularly by a man who
claimed to have made it to the pole
a year later Robert Peary by most
accounts Peary was a thoroughly
unpleasant man but for many years he was
widely considered to have led the first
expedition that actually reached the
North geographic pole in 1909 there's a
memorial to him on a high ridge at Cape
York in Greenland although literally it
was placed by his widow but he was the
only one on the final part of his
expedition that was trained in
navigation the only one who knew how to
use a sextant and all his claims really
don't add up in hindsight he almost
certainly wound didn't reach the pole
then there was u.s. naval officer
Richard Byrd his pilot Floyd Bennett who
claimed to have flown over the pole but
there are a lot of holes in their data
to a lot of over precise sextant results
that couldn't possibly be right even the
makers of their aircraft said they were
unlikely to have made it and it's not
like any of them could leave a flag or a
marker the North Polar pack ice the
fixed a lot of thin stuff we're going
through the real thick stuff is still
just floating around on the Arctic Ocean
and it drifts back and forth
roald amundsen led the first expedition
that provided convincing evidence they
reached the pole by airship but they
didn't land there they just flow over it
it was after the Second World War in
1948 when a Soviet expedition finally
set foot at the exact geographic North
Pole after flying there other explorers
reached the pole over the pack ice with
air support for the first confirmed
surface expedition to the North Pole
without resupply it took until 1986 when
after several attempts will Steger
finally achieved something that most of
us would assume some Edwardian explorer
had managed decades earlier nowadays if
you have enough money you can fly to the
pole or you can take a nuclear-powered
icebreakers you can check your GPS to
confirm it you can send a selfie back
via satellite phone
we're not going that far north onboard
the ship and we don't have a nuclear
reactor to give us enough power to get
through the thick ice up at the pole but
if all the fancy technology up on that
bridge fails we can still use the same
technique as explorers centuries ago and
track our position by the Stars at least
where we can see them I'm on this trip
because in Chris Hadfield generator
Arctic and so is this man my name is Ben
Brown and I am so lucky to be here right
now go check out his videos he provide
the amazing drone shots with this links
are on screen or in the description now
thanks man that's okay